an epic battle is playing out in
Washington no it's not between the
president and a politician instead Trump
is going toe-to-toe with Kellyanne
Conway's husband the two trading shots
on Twitter with George Conway unleashing
attacks like these claiming the
president is mentally unstable Americans
should be thinking seriously now about
Trump's mental condition and
psychological state including and
especially the media Congress and the
Vice President and cabinet and
congratulations you just guaranteed that
millions of more people are going to
learn about narcissistic personality
disorder and malignant narcissism great
job Trump of course counterpunching big
time by saying George is jealous of his
wife and calling him a quote stone-cold
loser and husband from hell
the president also serving up this
beatdown earlier I don't know him he's a
whack job there's no question about it
but I really don't know him he I think
he's doing a tremendous disservice to a
wonderful wife Kelli Ann is a wonderful
woman and I called him mr. Kellyanne the
fact is that he's doing a tremendous
disservice to a wife and family she's a
wonderful woman and Kelly and Conway is
responding to it all by defending Trump
saying quote he left it alone for months
out of respect for me but you think he
shouldn't respond when somebody a
non-medical professional accuses him of
having a mental disorder you think he
should just take that sitting down ok
well this happened all the time in the
Bush White House but so when it first
started if you go way back right this
has been going on for a while right so
George Conway not shy about tweeting but
it's been it's ramped up over time at
first it was just more like oh really
well see section 8 to 4 of the penal
code whatever and but then it ramped up
and it's often questions about the
president's mental health and there was
a profile of Kellyanne Conway and her
husband I think it was in The Washington
Post maybe like sort of last summer and
I
sending her note I thought this was the
funnest couple because they could have
these arguments they allowed the
reporter to come in their home as she's
cooking she starts singing to overcome
anything that he's saying and it looked
like like a fun family atmosphere where
you might have disagreements but you
don't let it interfere and now I feel
like I hope it is I hope I hope that it
is not bothering them I do think that
they have school-aged children all of
them can read the internet lives forever
and I'm sure everyone's aware of that
I'm not telling anyone something they
don't know but I have to say if Peter
had ever done this to me oh yeah well
that's a thing Peter has never ever done
anything like this to me so III feel for
them although I don't know if they
really care I don't know I know it's a
weirdest thing I've ever seen you
haven't seen Peters I hate Jasper a
website Greg this is like a scene from
veep but more entertaining I'm gonna
tell you why this story is the greatest
story that we've ever covered for me
because I love television I grew up on
sitcoms this is the greatest sitcom ever
George Conway is basically Newman from
Seinfeld right and so if Trump is
basically Seinfeld and and kellyanne's
Elaine but you got to have a Newman or I
was thinking maybe he's like mr. Roper
from Three's Company and Trump is Jack
Tripper and he'll because he's always
like staring at him with his beady eyes
he doesn't he does he's always mad at
him and this whole thing has got amazing
characters but we have to be honest
about what America wants to know what is
it like at home now is it just some kind
of knock down drag drag-out fight that
goes on to the night or is their love
life so insane
that it doesn't matter this is none of
my business right but I'm forced to
think about them having sex because and
that's something wrong with that but
this is what happens in the Trump
residency we have a crazy sitcom we have
like domestic fights publicly this is
the most transparent administration ever
because there's no such thing as behind
closed doors it's like when the
president says you know when I leave
office you guys
right about and that's true isn't it
yeah and I feel like this is an episode
of billions because the two Billy you
know it's like the husband and the boss
I do feel like it is not about you to
both of them and I feel like poor Kelly
and Conway is just trying to do her job
yes I forgot I was going to sit on my
hands name and I just yes and I just
feel really bad for her and I feel like
both of them
look she's the one that gets up every
morning and goes to work and then has to
now be caught between a rock and a hard
place her husband could have
demonstrated in this moment to me as a
learning moment as a teaching
opportunity for the rest of the country
as like a look even though we disagree
on everything I love my wife I support
her this is great like he could have
been a marvel and Madeline on your hand
[Laughter]
you can debate it with one hand behind I
have sympathy one because of mom texts
yeah we put this behind us and we all
have our issues you have sons who are
Republicans do you have any insight into
the situation well I like billions
because I think it's exactly what you
said in I think it's the the woman
between two powerful men I guess in
billions it's Wendy Rhodes between Chuck
Rhodes and and Bobby Axelrod the hedge
fund guy but here we have a situation
where I think lots of people were
talking about the president's mental
health this weekend when he was going
after John McCain I even have
Republicans defending John McCain Cindy
McCain saying it's parked all kinds of
nasty emails to her so lots of people
right because he went on a Twitter storm
so George Conway comes out he's talking
what was interesting about this is
George Conway puts up literal diagnosis
material from real doctors about
narcissistic disorder antisocial
behavior citing the president and that
leads them to what I you know I felt for
Kellyanne who's someone I've known for
many years because then she gets on TV
on Monday and people are saying do you
agree with your husband and she says
well no because of course she works for
the president she can't disagree with
the guy who's signing
paycheck but she went on to say that I'm
sorry the taxpayer sign our paper you
are
she works for President Trump and then
you know it was her
Brett maybe President Trump went on
decides he doesn't know George Conway
and then George Conway fired back so of
course I know you and I almost I had to
not take a job from you and you were
putting down Jeff Sessions you were
putting down John Bolton's mustache Isis
brings I mean it is it's literally as
Greg said like something out of TV
landed and I do think they might be
setting themselves up to be the next
Carville in matters yeah it's a reality
show it's all plan you think they're
gonna parlay this into a reality show
afterwards oh gosh I don't I I guess
we'll see what happens I don't think so
I don't watch it life is really good if
this is a problem this is entertainment
pretending to be a problem and I think
this is where Trump's kind of experience
with TV comes in is that he looks around
and goes we could have a little fun here
and I don't think he takes it as
seriously as anybody does I think it's
on us not to take it seriously because
we've been through this now for two the
president Trump thinks it's an insult to
be called by your wife's name right so
but this has happened to Peter a lot
because I have a public profile and we
go places and they're like Oh mr. Perino
and yes it's no joke what's going on in
terms of his putting down John McCain a
dead man people really are like that
there's a real psychological issue don't
mess with that stuff that that stuff is
so deep and ingrained that it's going to
be it's people have these feuds that go
beyond the grave and and it's not it's
it's in most historical figures have
these kind of problems yeah it's like
it's at this point complaining about
Trump's like personality is like
complaining about the weather
yeah we're two years in we know there's
a lot of storms gathering